great so I'm very happy that Irene is
here today to talk to us about
crowdsourcing information in informal
supply chains very much looking forward
to your talk
thank you for having me thank you for
all of you for staying for the last day
if they work shopping coming to my talk
I'm really excited to tell you about
this new project with Joe and Isaiah on
crowdsourcing information and informal
supply chains and this is ongoing work
part of this especially the experimental
part that I'm going to be telling you
about today is we we haven't even
started some of the experimental part so
we're really open to any comments or
feedback that you might have ok so let's
get started by talking about what our
informal supply chains and maybe if
you're not in operations you might also
have the question water supply chains so
I've pulled this helpful definition for
you from from Wikipedia supply chain is
a system of organizations people
activities information and resources
involved in moving a product or service
from a supplier to a customer so you
should bank I start out with some raw
products today we'll be talking about
palm fruit and we're thinking about all
the different parts of the chain that it
has to go up in order to become palm oil
which is a widely distributed product
what is an informal supply chain an
informal supply chain is a supply chain
where a lot of these links are created
informally and what this means is
usually they're created through informal
networks they're created through
word-of-mouth processes as a result a
lot of these supply chains operate
without the use so many written
contracts or a digitization of
transactions and they also frequently
operate without oversight or regulation
because it's just really hard to
regulate or monitor these kinds of
informal interactions
so well why is this an issue one big
issue in formal supply chains is that
information is not propagating well all
the way down the chain in particular a
lot of vias people at the end of the
supply chain are obtaining their
information through these word-of-mouth
informal processes this results in very
outdated or inaccurate information that
they're then basing decisions that
affect their entire livelihoods on this
kind of information particular over 60%
of global employment is sort of involved
in these informal supply chains labor in
these implement supply chains one
example of smallholder farmers those are
farmers who hold who farm on less than 2
hectares of land that's less than two
football fields and they actually
produce over 53% of global food calories
probably even more than 53 percent of
the workforce that's working on
producing these calories because they're
typically lower productivity they're
vulnerable populations they have high
risk of poverty this is sort of their
only source of income so it'd be really
great if we could improve the efficiency
of any part of the process
for example the informational part of
the process for these populations so a
large number of them are subsistence
production in this way they sort of yeah
I don't know the formal definition of
subsistence but I would say yeah if
you're just farming for yourself then
you wouldn't be able to sell but I don't
know which proportion of these small
holders are primarily farming for
themselves but then have like a small
knot on top of that I don't know this
was there
I'll be more specific about a specific
supply chain in a moment
on top of this I also think there's a
really great opportunity now we have a
lot of information technologies cell
phones are ubiquitous in a lot of these
settings even smartphones are becoming
more and more used and so this gives us
an opportunity to think about and design
ways to cemani information to all of
these people so I think there is a lot
of opportunity for really impactful
[Music]
great questions I'll answer all these
questions and our specific setting and
ice what we're gonna we we have an
actual information sharing platform but
we have actually deployed in this let me
describe all of that to you what is our
setting our setting is the palm fruit
supply chain and we're gonna focus on
the part the first smile the supply
chain that is located in a particular
part of rural in Tunisia why palm oil
palm oil is one of the most widely
produced vegetable oils worldwide in
2018 there was global demand for 73
million tonnes of this just as a
comparison global demand for olive oil
was 3 million tonnes global demand for
canola oil was 30 million tons so this
is like magnitude more it's used why is
it so widely demanded it's used in about
50 percent of packaged products
including chocolates cosmetics even
toothpaste as I noticed that actually
clearing land in order to farm foreign
full palm fruit is one of the leading
causes of deforestation and this is
actually one of the primary reasons that
my collaborator Joanne got interested in
this setting and so part of the hope is
that in reducing in efficiencies in
these supply chains will also somehow
reduce the incentives so you know just
acquire more land in the hope that that
will help you to make more money
Joanne also does a lot of direct work in
reducing deforestation and promoting
sustainability in these happy to talk
about any of that off why why Indonesia
Indonesia accounts for about 53 percent
of global production of palm oil that
makes up a huge amount of their foreign
exchange revenues and on top of that
within Indonesia
small holder farmers owned or managed
40% of pollination area and comprise
about 30% of their labor force and so
what we're really hoping is that
increasing the efficiency of any part of
the supply chain here will significantly
improve the livelihood of most
subsistence farmers or just these small
holder farmers and a lot of these
farmers are also the people who when
they or they find that they don't quite
have enough they're not quite generating
enough income from their current farming
practices they just sort of illegally
try to expand their farmland by
deforesting what's nearby and so we're
hoping also to
here's our setting and here's what the
supply chain looks like we're gonna be
talking today just about the first mile
of the supply chain and so what is this
we have our small holder farmers they
grow palm fruit and then they sell the
palm fruit to mills or processes at
mills who I sort of processed this and
do things to turn it into palm oil and
how this part of the supply chain works
is that the farmers don't directly sell
the fruit to the processors they sell
them to transportation middlemen who
come and pick up their fruit buy it off
them and then the transportation middle
then go and sell it to the mill what
happens is the processors well the night
before the processors will set their
prices there's some kind of process by
which they do this and then they'll
announce it to the middle and this is
the price I'm willing to pay tomorrow if
you bring me palm fruit and then the
middlemen will go and buy the fruit from
the farmers in the morning and then go
and transport and sell it at the
processors
this is how the process currently works
and ask your question of the harvest how
time constraint are you at that moment
is everything harvested at the same time
and actually I have no idea
that's like a question I don't know how
the harvesting works for comfort Joanne
would probably know the question is why
are the prices updating the process by
which the prices update is actually kind
of opaque there is supposed to be a set
formula that's based off basically the
the price for crude palm oil and that's
fluctuating daily and then there's meant
to be some set formula that the mills
and take that price and there's there's
some formula that's not really being
followed
because essentially Mills sort of look
at oh I'm trying to meet some quota
over the past month I was I didn't even
buy enough yesterday let me my price
today so more people come to me today so
they're verities fluctuation I don't
like the price today anyways
typically don't do that because the week
is a very yeah I'm not sure about next
day but I think also it's not so common
so you shouldn't think of the good is
perishable I you you should think of the
process as they want like a steady
stream of income so so they have been
high a large discount factors do they
want to sell kind of yeah yeah
okay so here is the supply chain that
we're looking at and let me just map it
back to those characteristics of an
informal supply chain that I described
earlier information and the supply chain
is actually created through a
word-of-mouth processes so what happens
is that the processes they don't just
post their prices it's not that they
decide in their price and the Nansen and
everyone suddenly magically learned the
prices what happens is that each of
these processors has a list of middlemen
that they think are likely to come and
sell to the processor and then they
contact just these middlemen
and how this list is maintained is all
very informal and I'm not sure exactly
how they do it but essentially there's a
lot of information out there but only a
small group of people are receiving this
information that it also has all these
other characteristics there are no
written contracts there's no record of
transactions there's very little
oversight and so what we're trying to do
is we want to come in and we want to
create a centralized platform for
middle-end the middlemen to share price
information and other price other
information that affects their effective
price with each other so what we're
doing in this platform is we set up a
platform where the middlemen and can we
are going to crowdsource prices from the
middlemen because each of the processors
are ascending price information to some
set of middlemen we want to crowdsource
this information amongst the middle then
while shutting down what we don't allow
the processors to look at the prices
offered by other processors so we're
trying to just look at the the
cooperation game between the middlemen
while sort of shutting down any possible
collusion between
and the hope is that if we introduce
this platform then somehow the right
people will get the right information
not sure exactly what I mean by that
right now but hopefully we'll have a
better sense later and then hope it's
also now that we have this one
centralized platform that's collecting
all this information and also collecting
information on transactions we'll be
able to start to address these other
issues as well voluntary information
sharing yeah this is a great question
and we actually deployed this platform
so it's interesting to see who uses it
possible for the middlemen to use our
we
yeah we haven't really thought through
first of all we haven't observed it
happening the platform has been running
for a year including it and today we're
gonna take a non-cooperative
we were designing such a platform as I
mentioned we're going to be taking a
non-cooperative game theory approach the
essence is that we have this information
sharing platform where middlemen can
share information with other at
middlemen but really they have no ones
that didn't do so right if you're
sharing information with the other
middlemen you're basically just
advantaging your competition so even
though in theory all the middlemen I'm
gonna call them firms from now on even
though all the firms alike the idea of a
crowd sourcing information platform if
we just put it out there in the wild
there's no reason for any of them to
contribute information
so the high-level question we have here
is how do we get incentivize information
sharing between these competing firms
how we've actually done it in the past
year but the platform has been
operational as we pay them some small
amount for every piece of information
every transaction that they record on
the platform now the platform has grown
a lot since we first deployed it and so
what this means is now every month we
are paying at about $2,000 to to various
middlemen so we're really really eager
to move to a stage where we incentivize
information sharing without using money
so that's what I'm going to be talking
about today I'm sorry understood what is
the I mean why should the middleman use
the platform except for getting money
from you I mean but what I'll talk about
today I'll spend a little more time
actually talking about the setting
because I want to talk about two parts
of this work the first part which very
time-intensive they're key to making
this project happen was a data
collection in the field so this was some
very important sub for them to
extensively engage with the community in
order to obtain a with what Joanne calls
a social licence to obtain data so to
build trust with the community I really
understand what they are looking for and
also then that trust allows them to
believe that such a platform is actually
for our good and not just you know
American researchers trying to exploit
them
using that we're able to start thinking
about what are the appropriate
objectives and questions they should be
asking investing as part of this data
collection there are lots of surveys 101
surveys as well as very time-intensive
manual data collection so like driving
through collecting GPS coordinates
following the middlemen recording their
actual activities and then based on that
data collection they identified thus
crowd sourcing information platform as
something that the middlemen themselves
really wanted and we're really on board
with and deployed then I'm also gonna
talk a little bit about the theory of
how do we incentivize information
sharing between competing firms without
using money
the key idea we're going to use is that
there's some kind of repeated or
stochastic game going on so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna pay for present
sharing with future information if you
share today you get to see tomorrow the
idea and on top of that what we do is we
use partial information disclosure
different middlemen may have different
value for being shown this additional
information so we do is we we simply sum
times show you more and we sometimes
show you less of what we have in order
to balance the games across all these
competing middlemen and mitigate the
effects of competition so even though
you sharing is helping your competitors
if you don't share and we revert to this
equilibrium where nobody's sharing
actually everyone is doing and
truthfulness is very important we we're
not considered we assume that reported
prices the prices are truthfully
reported in this work and and how we're
doing that in the actual platform is
they can only log price data once
they've actually transacted the mill or
the processor and they have to upload
their pricing
there's also when we set up the platform
there are very strict walls if you're
caught upload and fall false information
you will be back from the platform for
three months
but that's a very interesting it's not
here a very interesting question about
truthfulness I think there's room
eventually maybe to think about other
methods and be like peer grading pre
prediction type methods where you don't
know the ground truth we're not asking
them for receipts anymore and you want
to compare what they're saying to what
other people are saying in order to
determine whether what they're saying is
truthful I think there are some
interesting directions there if I have
time which I don't think I will also
like to tell you a little bit about some
field experiments that we're hoping to
deploy later this year which is
basically testing these very theoretical
policies I'm going to be showing you
today
okay quick slide and related literature
of course there's a huge and growing
amount of literature on information
sharing disclosure crowdsourcing
learning so on and so forth in online
platforms there's been a number of
really wonderful talks even just here at
Simons in this in this workshop in the
past few workshops and this is by no
means an exhaustive survey of all of
that work on top of that there's also
been a growing amount of work on the
impact information and developing world
markets these papers over here a
majority of them are empirical papers
where they deploy some kind of
informational intervention and a
developing world setting and what they
tend to find is that the welfare effects
of these interventions can be mixed but
what they're unable to do is identify
exactly what is driving these sort of
welfare gains or losses and so what
we're able to do is because we have a
very micro level data on our platform
hoping to tease out sort of who is
gaining is that because they are gaining
additional information and how valuable
is this information to them all these
kinds of questions we're hoping to be
able to collect enough data to answer
those that there's also a lot of even
fairly old work on information sharing
in supply chains or amongst competing
agents and we'll also be drawing a lot
of ideas from repeat and stochastic
games
Oh any questions before I tell you about
the fieldwork
yes that's the spatial distribution of
farmers and women and processes matter
good question the question was about
geography does the spatial distribution
matter yes it matters
most of what we're doing right now is
this platform hasn't been deployed just
in one village and so most of the
middlemen and processors are fairly
close together you'll see I'll show you
some graph with some price dispersion
the max price is usually one of the
processors is located a little more
remotely than all the other ones and so
as a result of that it creates as its
prices and so we are also collecting by
we aiming Joanne appeal team are also
collecting data on sort of
transportation costs and all of those
and hoping to use those and when we when
we try to formulate the utilities
in the future there's that were those
studies where people who are using cell
phones okay yeah
all right something great we don't see
that yet but I believe that it's likely
to happen price dispersion as a result
of increased information
and that may have effects also if you
take into account the capacity of those
meals that's that may have adverse
effects or positive effects later on the
supply chain right yeah yeah so in this
talk we are not considering capacity
constraints in part because those are
generally not an issue right now but
very relevant yeah what would that
propagating effects of this be
great so here's an overview of the
large-scale fieldwork that Joanne and
her team of 20-something field workers
in Indonesia with dad expand one and a
half years collecting over 4,000 former
surveys also surveying the middle men
who were during the year but trans
transporting of the fruit and also
collecting this Geographic data where
the process was located what do the the
roads look like that these middlemen are
driving across
one piece of this was establishing what
are the connections between barbers and
middlemen so we mentioned before that a
lot of the informational connections the
contracting the business relationships
are informal and so we wanted to take a
look at who - people know actually both
between the farmers and the middlemen
and then between the middlemen
processors so the established farmer and
middle in connections they survey the
farmers they surveyed the middlemen and
then there's this interesting piece in
the middle that is kind of coming out of
this informal setting what happens in
this informal setting is that people
have nicknames and it's really hard to
tell which knit nicknames referred to
which people let me give you some
examples ok so here's here's what the
farmer calls this middleman he calls him
I mean I can't pronounce in Tunisian but
Heidi okay but we also ask the middlemen
in this survey the nicknames for
themselves that were known to them
here's what he gave us kaeleen see John
Pocky sounds like I mean none of you
seem to match to each other from what I
can tell and so there was quite a bit of
field work that was done into just
making sure that these connections
between men and farmers middlemen and
processes is done correctly interesting
sidenote
did the thing bang for a metalman
processor connection and this was how he
discovered that how the prices were
being shared whereby abhi as SMS says
choose these selective lists of
middlemen where the where the processor
kind of via some decision-making process
decides these are the people worth
telling my prices right now in our
active on our app we have 50 something
processors yeah
but an active on the app we have
you can registered all the other we have
200 and something middlemen
and they belong in the same village so
in principle they could all transact
with each other yeah so they're all
roughly and like the same like clustered
like one two three villages they're all
really close they they're close enough
that they could talk to each other but
they form these social networks and sort
of stick to each other
then I also mentioned that they very
time-intensive Lee went and to track to
followed middlemen along there Ralph
tried to get an insight into the day a
day in the life of the middlemen what
what are the pain points what are the
bottlenecks
servus they were able to identify two
first-order issues in this particular
setting that the middle month really
wanted to pet improved the first was
transportation logistics so the july has
separate were looking at sort of helping
a little men decide which are the
optimal rats for them to take some some
kind of traveling salesman but also with
depending on the road conditions which
are highly varying because of weather
and they're not very good roads to begin
with what we're talking about today is
the other felt need which was just there
there was this sense that there was more
information out there than they were
getting and they thought it would be
really valuable to get this additional
information
so we talk quickly about these two
pictures here are the middlemen in the
middle there anonymized who we surveyed
in this initial survey Oh some of them
and here are the processors that they
were connected to so here on the pink is
the mill nhr and there are three
different processors of the mill in
nature and you can see that on average
every middleman is connected soon will
be two and abet processing processors
but together they're connected to a lot
of different ones and this is important
because the price is that all these
processors can actually be quite
different on any given day even if
they're exactly the same mill which
means they're at basically the same
location
so it seems like there there could be
the middle men could be obtaining better
prices if they had access to this
information
okay and so in response to that Joann
and her team rolled out this app you can
go and download it on google play and
even play with it if you speak
Indonesian it's called pimping pen
stands for book I think for a buyer and
from something else for a supplier and
what you can do in this app is you can
see you go in let's say I want to look
at the prices at nhr I can click in HR
and then click through to the specific
processes at an HR and share the price
information or I can share their
information right now a few options are
equate grading weighing bridge
calibration and that's good if I bring X
tonnes they're only good they only paid
me today 4.9 X times like that and so
this is the kind of information that's
being shared I had a question so I
wonder whether you know you're holding
cups and the fact that the processors
are going to disclose those prices and
they're not gonna change their price
decision as a function of how much the
middlemen talk but if you go to full
transparency there may be a situation in
which actually the response of the
processors is to lower the prices for a
so far we've talked about this a little
what we're trying to do at least this
should shut down any colluding between
the processors and so if they're not
able to see each other's prices it's a
little harder for them to do this but I
mean that if I am a processor I may be
more willing to offer a high price to a
high quality middleman and a low price
to I mean the the unike they're not just
offers yeah yeah so so the price I'm
showing here is just this is sort of
like their max price the grading is
referring to how they rate the quality
of the fruit your brain and so if a low
quality metal membranes I mean if I'm
middlemen brings low quality for then
their price will be adjusted to
so they're not worried about the quality
of the middlemen who are arriving
so here's what they can do on the
platform this platform has been active
since December of last year there are
now over 300 a registered user is about
88 whoever active every day by active I
just mean they they log in and they look
at information how many of them actually
share information and there is about 50
of them who are sharing information
every day well every day there's about
50 who share information
most of the middlemen are not using it
every day because most of them are not
working every day there's a lot who do a
sort of the several days or weekly or
every two week kind of cycle and we have
55 active processors and I as I
mentioned we are paying everyone for
what they share yes yeah so this
I don't think anyone outside this area
has actually downloaded I'd like uh uh
how like what is the total number of
middlemen in this area that is a very
good question I do not know
I know that we have a lot more active
processors that have been suggested let
me show you some results okay so here's
the setting and let me show you some
theoretical results how can we design an
information-sharing platform that
incentivizes information between these
competing agents and doesn't use money
to do so
okay here's a model we're gonna blitz
through it here all the pieces you need
for the model there are the firm's these
are transportation middlemen the firm's
and here's the finite set of buyers and
we start out with some initial
information
okay everyone has some initial volume
and they also have connections
symbolized by these arrows with some of
these buyers in them they have some
utilities which I'm now going to specify
for you so how do these utilities come
about
you're the firms here the bias we're in
an infinite time horizon game every
period we draw the prices at each of the
buyer so we're just assuming that the
prices that the buyers are exogenously
given and they're drawn iid they could
be correlated with each other but they
draw an IAD over time from this
distribution prices and then middlemen
see the prices or firms see the prices
for the buyers who they are connected to
in their initial information some of
that firms have utilities it's basically
just how much volume the firm is selling
times the per unit profit
and the per-unit prophet takes into
account both the price at the mill that
they're selling to and also the cost
okay and the firm's are trying to
maximize their expect to discover
utility
how competition comes into play here is
that these firms or the middle winner
effectively splitting the overall volume
which is all the fruit all the farmers
who are selling fruit okay and we have
this particular formulation we say that
how much of the market you are
possessing depends on your previous time
periods utility as well as your previous
time periods all may not go too much
into this exact formulation there are
some parts of it that we need for
technical reasons right now there are
some parts of it which we can relax in
other ways but then we have to put in
new assumptions happy to talk offline if
you want to micro founded you could but
I don't really believe this all that
much so let's let's keep going
information what is the platform doing
what we want to do is crowdsource and
market information from the firms so we
do is were essentially trying to
increase the information
and for the purposes of today you should
just think of this platform as some
disclosure policy that can be committed
to okay based on the history of the
prices who shared what when which
information to show which firms at every
single time period and then this
strategy is based on the histories
whether to share or not share
information this is probably the the
simple simplest strategy is you can
think of for the middlemen what I'm
gonna say today also goes through if you
allow for more complicated strategies
timeline is in every period the firm's
arrival I'm missing something
the prices are realized the firm's
arrive and they see the prices in their
information set them they share with the
platform according to the policy and
then the platform takes that information
and discloses to middlemen according to
its policy and then the middlemen take
that information and go and sell
just notation Sigma s is everyone
sharing every period Sigma n s is nobody
sharing some sake you think of the price
terminations
yeah yeah yeah so we're worse why that's
a good question
yeah so we we thought about that
somewhat I forget I forget why we we did
think about it but I forget why we win
this yeah all right now that's a
question I should have an answer for
here's some assumptions that we have we
have that the utilities are separable in
the price and volume we have found a
preferred unit profit we want firms to
sell to buyers that maximize profit here
we're going to assume that all middlemen
can gain from share and information so
there's no one who's holding on to a
whole bunch of information but doesn't
want any of the other information that's
being shared we can sort of work around
that in the paper and we're just gonna
assume that the total volume is one
so what are our theoretical results I'm
just going to state them for you I'm not
gonna have time to do anything else here
are the main ideas first main idea is
that information sharing platforms with
full disclosure induce complicated
information sharing so if you know the
repeated games literature essentially
what we would like to have here is some
kind of folk theorem where we say that
you can and use all sorts of strange
strategies you can induce a large set of
equilibria through a grim trigger
strategies
we can't quite get an exact volk theorem
because there's all sorts of lot not
only and linearity going on here that's
right mind you can get a lot of outcomes
if you just put out this platform in the
wild and and what the middlemen
themselves decide who gets to see what
so the second main idea is once we have
this platform which we have complete
control over and is the only source of
information for people then we can
design how the platform discloses
information in order to simplify this
game it can make it so that they're just
too vocal in calabria are they're you're
all sharing a girl not sharing and we
can we can sort of select what we want
the outcome to look like under the whole
sharing
I had an example to walk you through
sort of what are the main ideas that are
going into this and what makes us
different from a standard repeated games
kind of problem I'm definitely not gonna
have time to go through this example but
let me just highlight for you the key
findings so let's say we have this
example there are just two firms there
are three buyers and they're connected
in this way so one is connected to one
two is connected to two they're all
connected to three and there's some
correlated prices some cost
in this particular setting I set it up
exactly so that when there's no sharing
then the profits are symmetric between
the two firms in one realization of the
world one of them gets profit to the
other gets profit one and the other
realization I mean every realization of
the prices every period rather and the
other realization if its tail's the
first gets one and a second goes to
exactly symmetric we know what will
happen they'll sort of keep the same
they'll split the market share and have
expected per period profit of one and a
half
it's only two shares and obviously they
do worse than not sharing because
they're just giving valuable information
to the other firm and so in in general
not sharing it's going to be a sub game
perfect Nash equilibrium yeah well we
really want to do is get out of this bad
equilibrium and have people share okay
and so if they just if we mandate
sharing and that's not going to help
because I set it up in this particular
example so that if everyone shares - in
any realization of prices is getting a
higher profit than 1 4 versus to five
versus four okay and so if we do this
then you go through you look at how the
volumes evolve and you see that
eventually the middle firm one will have
what will more than have so they'll have
less than half of their original volume
which means that double the profits is
not good enough
okay but if we do this very complicated
partial sharing okay
one shares only when it's heads two
shares all the time then all of a sudden
everyone's profits have exactly doubled
right I've gone from 2 1 to 4 - 1 - 2 -
1 - 2 - 4
everyone's profits have exactly double
and so the volumes are this competition
for volumes everyone's still going -
exactly
split the market but now everyone's
profit that's doubled so everyone is
doing better off
so these are all the main ideas that we
put together to get the following
the no sharing strategy is always a sub
game perfect Nash equilibrium but
there's a grim trigger strategy profile
where there's usually partial sharing
that can be sustained as a sub game
perfect Nash where everyone is doing
better off so they're limiting utility
is strictly higher
so this is under full platform
disclosure this is just the S sub game
perfect Nash equilibrium and the
question is how do we get the one that
we want
I had another example to show how we can
do that the main idea is that now the
platform is basically playing the role
of the of the grim trigger right if you
don't play according to your strategy
the platform is going to shut down
information sharing with you so now
whatever all the middle wouldn't have to
do is they just have to share and the
platform is doing all the work
deciding who gets to see what we're just
taking the action from the middlemen and
giving it to the problem okay and so by
doing this what we can do is we can
simplify the game here's the informal
statement if we use this kind of a grim
trigger platform then there are
essentially only to pay off relevant
national career one where everyone
shares and one where nobody shares what
that means and we have a way for
constructing be as good equilibria what
we do is we balance the volumes or the
share of the market people obtain and so
what that means is well first of all
everyone's welfare is going to improve
but then it also makes you add incentive
compatible for you to share deviate and
you go to this equilibrium where you get
the same volume and you have less profit
so we find a way to construct these we
construct a particular one where we're
always showing to someone all the
information
and we can show that this particular
policy we've constructed is showing the
most information possible
while still maintaining the balance of
market share
so this is ongoing work there are lots
of questions you might be having a big
one that yes I should really talk to all
of you offline and get your thoughts on
is what this is due to prices yeah the
latest of that is sort of how do we
think of collusion between the firms
between the buyers right now in order to
get this out there and running what
we're thinking about is how can we
efficiently compute these how do we
observe the information we need to learn
these functional forms which we've just
sort of specified in this way are there
ways that we can be able to do
approximately well without knowing
exactly how the volumes and utilities
are involved evolving but by just
observing how they evolve
rather than having a model for how they
evolve and in our setting also can we
can we punish without having to punish
forever and in our setting it seems like
yes because there are multiple people
who have access to any single piece of
information
I don't have time to tell you about the
field experiment but we do want to set
up a field experiment there are lots of
things there how do we we're assuming
middlemen are rational other ways we can
help them be more rational through the
platform you can give them price
notifications or recommendation
in order to implement this grim trigger
policy we have this sort of token based
system that we're going to use so you
get a token for sure without that you
can't use in future periods and this is
important because middlemen are not
coming to the platform every day so
there are lots of these little things
that we have to think through in order
to the play
[Applause]
let's talk later I think we are over
time so thank you very much Irene for
the nice talk